it's Thursday April second and this is
gamespot news I'm Chris waters and my
appearance here means either ed and Jess
are enjoying a much-deserved vacation or
things down under have gone full-on fury
road or both either way there's a lot of
news in the past 24 hours let's run it
down Nintendo hosted a press conference
yesterday and unleashed a barrage of
announcements that I will now run
through for you super quickly super
smash brothers is getting new characters
Mewtwo and Lucas nuni fighter costumes
and you can vote for the next dlc
character which should obviously be
tetra they're a bunch of new amigo
coming including super cute bully
Yoshi's a bunch of kardam evos and an S
figure that multiple gamespot editors
skip their lunch breaks to preorder and
fail the latest fatal frame game
currently out only in Japan will be
coming to the west for all you horror
fans out there there were new trailers
for shin megami tensei cross fire emblem
and Fire Emblem 3ds there will be new
StreetPass games an attack on Titan game
for 3ds and n64 India's games are coming
to wii u virtual console there's a free
update for mario kart 8 coming on april
23rd that introduces a new super speedy
200cc mode and Pokemon world rumble is
coming out on april eight and splatoon
on may 29th for more in-depth info on
all that business go to gamespot com /
news what does quantum break have in
common with The Legend of Zelda Wii U
and uncharted 4 a thief's end it's been
pushed to 2016 the time bending shooter
by Alan Wake developer Remedy
Entertainment is still being developed
alongside a live-action TV show that
remains in production following the
closure of Xbox entertainment studios
last year release on time the witcher 3
who are our only hope though blood-borne
hype is still burning bright like the
fires of old the arnhem a remastered
version of Dark Souls 2 is coming to ps4
and xbox one and guess which one it runs
better on ps4 at least according to a
report by digital foundry according to
their tests both formats target 60 FPS
and engage vsync at all times but
Microsoft platform suffers the greater
drops between the two in each scene of
our frame rate analysis so if you're
torn on
platform to get scholar of the first sin
on answer seems pretty clear PC let's
round out the show with three quick hits
first up elite dangerous the massive sci
fi space combat and exploration sim is
now on steam in addition to being
purchasable from the games website
number two battlefield hardline is
getting its first big patch which
includes bug fixes gameplay tweaks and a
serious nerfing of the American dream
everyone's favorite drivable couch and
finally gamespot production manager ty
root almost caused an international
incident by placing his electric tea
kettle on an actual stove and attempting
to heat it up you can enjoy these and
more shenanigans on his new Amazon Prime
original series tyro technics and there
you have it whole bunch of news for you
to ingest digest Andrey jest yes I made
that last word up no I don't know what
it means maybe it's what cows do for
more video game news go to gamespot com
/ news and I'll see you tomorrow for the
top five stories of the week Mad Max
he's the Metis Maxo there ever was oh we
don't need another hero we don't need a
father way home all we want is who we
are Thunder don't